we're gonna kind of start over last
night okay so when I do that t1 and in
Ag on you have to really pick up on the
concepts and then there's what I'm going
to call master key moves there's aspects
of the technical narrative that are
universally Marshall then there's other
aspects that are just particulars
relevant only to that in there okay so
we're going to work out you're gonna go
with me and feel my technique I'm going
to pay attention to those master key
moves okay and we're going to find did
gu with in 81
okay it is in there just following the
Guardian s tech dilemma and there's you
can't really make
okay so you'll see when you just do your
form it's not relevant to the knot that
you gave you have that is exactly like
picking a technique in g1 okay all right
so we'll just start and we'll go to you
Nikki oh well just to work EQ okay and
say like Center will not help rejection
skills and projection skills really help
in g1 okay so you still have some
technical mechanical issues they should
have to address as well okay got it
right here
you see you did and that's awareness and
that gets in the way of what you want to
see she's dead on the map but not to see
and waiting for me to pull her around
you want to be more alive also the
here and again and you guys love this
and that disconnect is your mouth not
training in the intentional connection
and that makes in the way you want you
see so you use your techniques to see
out with her
I got my antenna going I'm aware of her
arm I'm not waiting for her I shouldn't
have to pull the experience Duke is over
because Buddha is a turkey maneuver
correct so do you think it is providing
what they pulling or pushing and okay
[Music]
yeah
go
[Music]
can you come forward no detectable
that's why you go around and you don't
contest
you know
[Music]
the extra train that so Piazza is a
ritual like a marriage ritual so the
groom has his role his words his body
movement to perform and so does the
bride okay you can't do your thing and
she does her thing or vice versa
okay so just as if you were trying to
learn
the marriage visual it has to happen via
no one gets right the first time so part
of p1 wasa is you might look at that as
a bad thing it's only bad if you quit
because you never heard what you were
actually okay it's less good for the
food game who continues to do that who
continues not to learn the ritual of
losing so for example the the bouquet
who does not give final displacer they
never learn how to read
or isolated group muscle group in place
of extension they're using tension not
extension or the bouquet who constantly
disengages their Center at projection
okay but that we get is really good for
the knocking has not quit because that
gate is bringing in a hell of a lot of
jiwan's ax into the keyboard you get it
okay
so undoubtedly everybody is trying to
learn the form undoubtedly
Luke it might not be where you are in
terms of your noggin loss of skill there
you can still is not where you are so
you need to take advantage of them okay
and their learning process is not your
responsibility it's the teachers
responsibility so instead you get to do
some jiwan's of it and the teacher fixes
them later
don't don't don't force them needed a
technique find the subtle adaptations
where you now are practicing spontaneity
with an end result in mind this is
much more sophisticated you wanna than
just do you want because in regular do
you wanna you can't go wherever he goes
but at this time she was up you have to
end up at the same damn train station
you go wherever you wanna go in the city
to get there roadblock here is all
around me but I'm still heading to the
train station if this is more akin to
jazz rock right it's still the song you
can hear the song in it you see that
it's not the same thing when you just
start playing whatever yeah alright so
some of the things are seen is that you
can't has isolated shoulder tension
there usually that in place to defend
the mouth okay so they come around go
and she's really pushing there so it he
won't and you understand that you see
but his human law that she's really
pushing there I have to figure out how
to do this okay do you see how much
anguish she has
on me there because she's really pushing
it can't you defend the column no she
can't because I choose she left that bit
inner angle open you see that
so the beginner thinks this is going to
stop that guy from doing all my head but
it doesn't really okay got it
okay so because you're you're not doing
the internal aspect your extra last way
so you only have one mind you don't have
my Center and I just move the needle
okay so Butler you can experience it is
I can't I can't move because there's so
much angle this way well guess what that
condition see that Huff's condition here
for corner integrity okay so what
usually do is you going to see and then
you step in how you make it worse okay
so leave it where it is and practice it
it doesn't change but you have to do
that you would be doing that in the all
right so I go and walk around where you
can see right you see how much tension
there and this is the holdup
okay little ignore it okay
so I do not have that four corner
integrity you have to set the shoulder
okay now here's what here's the solution
you guys use instead you see that but
big strong people no no you will never
work okay and you are becoming
depending which means your group
enslaves and then Speidel eyes that
they're countering it won't work so you
over here and they punch you or they
come under something like that okay so
we're back go back in that last so you
see where you're up on this past the
elbow because she's what she's doing
just make one more circle do you see
that one more circle and now keep the
four corner integrity set the shoulder
and this hand was there I'd make another
circle and now what I removed look you
see and this hand was just resting it's
not gripping yet but you can see I'm
coming out right there okay and once I
come out this hat falls into the other
hand and I was in group to Kenda okay so
it happened a lot on that weekend okay
don't worry
set the shoulder lock before one wearing
awkward corner
right it would make more sense to go in
here like hey I'm going to use it so I
go one more circle woman and it falls in
together okay that's how you note that
it is my job help or not yeah that
doesn't work okay go if you take out
please
then we're further back so you didn't
have your cross lateral arm with
consciousness and awareness and
you see that so now we're go to another
girl to add that back in and we're not
progressing okay so we are working on
this everything else up to that okay
[Music]
this hat it does touch not pull it
there's no pulling
I don't see you won't see my elbow on
that one this hands doing what it was
doing at this hand guys I look
okay lawyers hello
oh I will change Ronin hole okay look
this are you going like this and you
want you know I won't enter until it's
ah it's always commit position or
submission ng all day I'm moving and the
movement
oh it's not this is moving
[Applause]
there is no no
don't finish eagle forget it yo y'all
doing if you assume - you were doing -
you're right so don't do it you just do
my so the quarter waterfall and when you
step behind
so you can also challenge yourself over
challenge yourself okay so when you go
over here and you step over here like
you did that's a big thing to do now
this is a lot of torque on the four
corners you got it
so why not step where it's not so bad
you get it so you're here like this you
do the loop you see it over here
I'll see y'all okay watch what you have
what you have you it doesn't push
but at the beginning don't over sound
yourself so their body is telling
where you go capital here Jewish
leadership town to it and then I mean so
pay attention there as near as I can
okay let's go yes why why today
is that okay
[Music]
you can't see why or the work so he
won't do it okay
you're supposed to be here and you're
going to just do it one more time do you
got it
look if you changed your hair pasta
elbow they give you a loop and now
you're not fat cells then inter turn
your body keeps lighting energy book so
keep behind like that don't give up
there's no look down it goes do you guys
get that little fight huh
passing stop your life not seeing it not
gonna do it anyway that's why your
you need to see it then you twit
now you understand okay so I'm here who
cares
spin the rest here who cares
spin the wrist did your lunch money can
take my truck in your car what are you
say you what
[Applause]
[Music]
it's okay but it's not doing now okay
it's starting to Center when you over
challenge yourself see that okay we fix
it I go on and now I'm pushing him way
out and I cannot get the EDB rotation
and even though it's easy me even though
it's linear there is a dunker by
incurred in et me you get it so all I'm
doing is pushing him away that means
he's not underneath that means I'm not
controlling him and we're gonna keep
fighting okay so same thing
combined what do I want the hammer to do
with a bunch of my feet are doing okay
that's where I'm doing look at the curve
and see the curve
I'm not pushed enough I'm curving in
pushing them forward already and so when
you push down you know how that annual
that's happy well then you don't really
have to follow but more importantly the
master key moves coordinate with us
lucky you don't have that concept and so
we wouldn't you want everything every
mechanical feeling you have is too low
okay try it again
we went to the handle but the first
cookie production and the first item
deviation and total oh okay
you don't have the projection capacity
you don't feel we're easy though so you
will understand why are you in front it
up because you have to keep them out why
because you don't have that internal
absorption skills so you just are doing
here Fred cycles you get back how do I
go well what happens when the person
comes into your body right well that's
what you're trying to push and you get
you the person has more more mass more
velocity if you're gonna lose the worst
place you get it so that's why we worked
on that really this effort stop is it
you little traitor did you get it and
here's some adaptation if you're
something she was I guess it's
unconsciousness because you try to do it
in this real life but be able to
energy was but if you learn right how to
make that first projection that first
projection is more of a master key move
then this little handle okay so some of
the things I've seen is your state
normal line it doesn't have to be a big
huge thing and the bigger you make it
the less fat raise a massive ki-moon and
now with this becomes one of the
elements of the narrow okay but because
if you as you saw when the dudes coming
in with whatever right good whatever I
can't go like this it doesn't work okay
it's gotta be very something up I was it
do we want the I'm going to get the
angle right there you see this angle is
line and then the so the more I can make
my initial technique and then I
recommend there's the it right is
orchard here comes down and once you get
that you don't have as much of the
challenging annual that requires the
wrist flip you see that so because you
don't have I hurt shut down which was
supposed to be over here is over there
and you need the wrist flip but if you
have the other one
or change the whole relationship boom ah
not on this channel
okay thanks